يبدو الان في قطاع غزه كما نشاهد في
الشاشه
نحن بانتظار ان نعرف اين تقع هذه المنطقه
التي سقطت فيها هذه القذائف الصاروخيه
الاسرائيليه ولكن هذه الصور مباشره تاتينا
من قطاع غزه وكانت كانت قطاع غزه اليوم
مسرحا للعمليات بشكل كبير اذ افاد مراسلنا
بتدمير منزلين في منطقه اليرموك وحي
الشجاعيه بمدينه غزه التي كنا
نشاهدها على الخريطه التفاعليه ولكن هذه
صور لغارات جديده على الشاشه في مدينه غزه
اذا
اذا اليك مريم لمتابعه هذه التفاصيل
والتطورات الجديده اذا نتابع مثلما ذكرت
هذا القصف الجديد الذي يستهدف غزه خلال
هذه اللحظات
وما يبدو انه قصف مكثف يستهدف موقعا سنسال
هبه عكيله مراسله في غزه عنه واين يكون او
ماذا يكون قد استهدف هبه
نعم هذا القصف الذي شاهدناه هو على منطقه
جنوب مدينه غزه هذه المنطقه التي تلقت منذ
الامس وحتى اليوم عدد كبير من القذائف ومن
الصواريخ هذا المنطقه في جنوب مدينه غزه
هي غاره كما شاهدتم معنا
من
الادخنه المتصاعده يبدو انها في ارض فارغه
لم تلحق هذه الادخنه تصاعد اي اتربه او
اخرى
ولكن هو استمرار لسلسله الغارات التي كان
قد شهدها قطاع غزه بشكل متتالي خلال ايام
التصعيد الخمسه
منذ صباح هذا اليوم وحتى الان نتحدث منذ
فجر فقط هذا اليوم وحتى الان تم تدمير
ثلاث بشكل كامل في قطاع غزه الحديث عن 14
منزلا
اي بنايات بعده طوابق
وسته شقق سكنيه هي الشقق التي استهدفت في
اغتيالات قيادات سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلاميه هذه كانت
الاستهدافات المباشره بلغت 20 منزلا حتى
الان ولكن بالتاكيد هذا العدد لا ينم
حقيقه عن حجم التدمير في الوحدات السكنيه
والمباني عشرات بالفعل من الشقق السكنيه
تم تدميرها بالكامل عشرات من الشقق
السكنيه دمرت بشكل جزئي ولكنها لم تعد
تصلح للسكن كذلك هناك اضرار كبيره في
المباني السكنيه وفي الشقق في المناطق
التي يتم فيها
استهدافات او قصف كما شهدتم الان هذه
الغاره هذه الغاره كما تلاحظون كانت وسط
منطقه مكتظه وسط ابنيه متلاصقه هذا المكان
او او جميع الاحياء في غزه كما تعلمون هي
من اكثر المناطق في العالم كثافه سكانيه
وبالتالي هذه المناطق السكنيه غاره جديده
الان اذا تشاهدون معي غاره جديده الان في
منطقه الشمال في منطقه الشمال على اطراف
بيت لاهيه الى الشمال من مدينه غزه هذه
الغاره كنا نتحدث ايضا عن وتيره هذه نعم
كنا نتحدث خلال اطراف بيت لاهيه كما ذكرته
باذا